[Music]
the rtp
and the position of fast manages the
operations
of seven nevada traffic signals um on
behalf of the local agencies so since
this particular project the eastern
traffic signal adapter project goes
between both city of henderson and clark
county
we need to make sure that we get our
partners involved because they are the
owners of the signals and we are the
operators of them and we always want to
make sure
that they are on board with what we are
doing and that we're doing this
jointly so that we can make sure that
we're enhancing safety for the whole
public
the purpose of this project is to trial
some adaptive
traffic signal software to understand
what that can do to enhance the
operations of our signal system
so the beauty of the adaptive signal
traffic system
is that it's constantly evaluating
what's happening
with the traffic volume all day long
in real time so typically we run
kind of date plans that have certain
parameters that they work within
a dynamic system starts with those base
parameters
and then determines if there's
efficiency making the gains in the
system
to help minimize delay and increase
respect
so a left turn that you're typically
used to starting off a signal phase
might not actually lag a signal phase or
sensor demand it may not serve at all
so we do encourage everybody just to
really pay attention when you're out
there because
like always traffic and is always
[Music]
changing